In Indonesia, repairs to electricity infrastructure was underway...
...in Donggala, Pasangkayu districts on Thursday,...
...the seventh day since central Sulawesi was hit by a powerful earthquake and tsunami.
In Belgium, NATO Secretary General Jens Stoltenberg warned Russia...
...to halt its "reckless" behavior...
...amid a series of global cyberattacks blamed on Moscow.
India's top court allows Rohingya to be deported to Myanmar in an unprecedented move.
In the US, seven police officers were shot, one of them fatally,...
...as they responded to the scene of an unidentified gunman...
...holding children hostage in Florence, South Carolina.
Finally from Japan, the Okinawa islands are bracing for powerful Typhoon Kong-rey,...
...which has maximum sustained winds of 126 kilometers per hour...
...with gusts to 180 kilometers per hour.